[Music]  to some health news this afternoon  this year more than 100 000 americans  will be diagnosed with melanoma  the most serious form of skin cancer but  researchers have encouraging news they  call it the future of skin cancer  screening and it lies in this odd shaped  machine it takes pictures of you from  all angles  and then a computer builds a highly  detailed 3d image  we're bottom line trying to leverage  technology  to help do a better job to catch  melanoma at the earliest possible stage  while at the same time avoiding a lot of  unnecessary biopsies  dermatologists say they're working with  some of entertainment's top engineers to  try and bring some of their tech  such as ai into a clinical environment  to save lives